We ended the last quiz with this equation, but if we add k to both sides, we
could end up with this equation, u equals x squared minus 2hx plus h squared
plus k. So here, y is by itself on one side, and then all of the x terms and
constants are on the right side. We've seen a number of equations for parabolas
that are in this form, even if we didn't see general forms of them written with
constants like these. So let's compare this to another parabola. Maybe y equals
x squared, plus 6x plus 5, now because these two equations are in the same form,
we should be able to figure out the value of each of the constants over here,
based on the value of constants over here. So compared to this general equation,
in equation y equals x squared plus 6 x plus 5, what number is h equal to? So
find where the constant h appears in this general equation, figure out where
that corresponds to in our equation with particular values inserted, and then
calculate age based on that. This is a little bit tricky, but just give it a few
tries.